[Musique]
bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette nouvelle édition du journal de la
rédaction voici les titres de ce 17
janvier 2017 en raison de l'épidémie de
grippe c'est l'inquiétude qui gagne
l'établissement français du don du sang
la pénurie s'installe le primaire de la
belle alliance premier tour ce dimanche
dernier était placement pour les
candidats arnaud montebourg était aux
mureaux et puis dorénavant chaque mardi
la rédaction vous proposera un portrait
d'yves illinois aujourd'hui rencontre
avec le chirurgien christian couturier
fondateur de l'antenne et soes main à la
clinique privée de trapèze
le froid s'installe donc en france et
dans les yvelines pour plusieurs jours
sur l'ensemble de la france
une situation qui pousse donc les
autorités et les associations à la
mobilisation néanmoins nous sommes
encore loin des records de 2012 avec un
nouvel épisode avec glacial qui avait
duré pendant près de deux semaines nous
sommes allez vous demander comment vous
faisiez face à ce froid
micro-trottoir d'alice deschamps et de
mathilde et demi je mets des vêtements
d'hiver
je mets mon gros à l'amont gros manteau
ma grosse parka et puis mon bonnet et
puis je mens me souffle et un bonnet
chevet des gants et je respire bien je
m'habille fondement avec mon manteau je
fais ce que je peux et surtout j'évite
les transports en commun je prends ma
voiture et du québec et on a beaucoup
plus froid ici donc pour moi je suis
relativement bien il s'est toujours un
foulard dégâts et une tuque en général
mais en général j'ai tendance à mettre
le chauffage un peu plus fort chez que
c'est pas bien mais on aime bien être
allé à la maison j'ai dit se fait ch
supplémentaires en fait voilà des en
plus du fioul
je rajoute des couches et il fait
tellement froid que c'est presque le
seul moyen après
ouais je pense que c'est le mektoub on
utilise façon moi j'utilise des gants
pinocchio je suis couvert de partout
donc taches de sang je vais marcher dix
minutes j'ai peur
les fameux gant pilou pilou pour se
réchauffer avec le froid en tout cas
c'est la grippe qui a fait son grand
retour et face à l épidémie actuelle
l'établissement français du sang tire la
sonnette d'alarmé et lance une campagne
d'urgence les besoins en produits
sanguins sont en hausse explications au
micro de haussmann vandeurzen
nous sommes en réserve tout à fait
instable est insuffisante
il faut savoir que l'établissement
français du sang
on aime bien avoir quatorze jours de
réserve et qu'actuellement on est en 11
jours 11 jours et demi
c'est à dire globalement on aimerait
avoir cent mille produits en réserve et
nous n'en avons que 73 me de ses tirs 25
% un quart de réserve en moins donc les
difficultés et les appels aux dons
au chapitre politique à présent l'état
et l'association habitat et humanisme
s'associent pour lutter contre le
mal-logement un phénomène et qui
toucherait près de 4 millions de
français l'accord a été signé
aujourd'hui à jouy en josas dans les
yvelines donc par la ministre du
logement emmanuelle cosse dans la toute
nouvelle maison intergénérationnelle qui
a été construite dans cette commune le
reportage de michael mais dont la
ministre du logement emmanuelle cosse
était à jouy en josas ce mardi 17
janvier
la représentante du gouvernement 1 signé
à cette occasion une convention
d'engagement d'utilité sociale avec
habitat et humanisme une association qui
lutte depuis 30 ans contre le mal
logement et l'insertion des personnes en
difficulté la corse établi sur la
période 2017 2020 c'est un engagement
que le président de la république m'a
demandé
renouvelée notamment en mai dernier en
me demandant de réouvrir dans les 57
mille cinq cents places de pension de
famille qui sont vos loyers des
structures qui sont à cheval entre eux
on va dire un centre d'hébergement et un
logement pérenne avant cette signature
la ministre a également visité les
locaux de cette maison
intergénérationnelle implantée avenue
jean jaurès cette dernière comprend 48
logements sur deux bâtiments
au total 80 personnes devraient
s'installer dans la structure d'ici fin
février la volonté de la date du projet
et c'est d'avoir un une mixité il y à
des familles des familles normales landa
si on peut dire
il y à des seniors isolés
il y à des personnes isolées il y a des
moments des familles monoparentales et
des étudiants et des jeunes travailleurs
la maison intergénérationnelle ouvrira
officiellement ses portes le samedi 21
janvier avec cette inauguration
l'association habitat et humanisme
dépassera les deux mille familles logées
depuis sa création
politique toujours les voeux continue
sur l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines vendredi soir c'était au tour
de maurepas le maire grégory gars
restiez add on qui a dressé le bilan de
l'année écoulée il a évoqué notamment la
réhabilitation la de différents
établissements scolaires celui de la
marnière ou encore celui est des friches
les travaux vont continuer durant
l'année 2010 est il a surtout profité de
cette cérémonie pour annoncer le projet
d'un centre aqualudique ecoutez-le
depuis maintenant un an nous travaillons
à que mes deux amis collègues maires de
coignières et d'elancourt sur un nouveau
projet parce qu' il vaut mieux détruire
et reconstruire en lieu et place du site
actuel plutôt que de bricoler dans une
structure qui de toute façon était en
fin de vie et ça coûte et même plus cher
donc on repart sur un nouveau projet on
est en train de justement de terminer le
montage financier que l'agglomération de
saint quentin on a toutes espérances
également que les intérêts
communautaires soit voté pour que le
chantier soit lancé la primaire de la
belle alliance premier tour ce dimanche
en attendant les candidats pour suivre
leurs déplacements et hier arnaud
montebourg était dans les yvelines il
s'est rendu aux mureaux pour rencontrer
les associations locales le commentaire
de camille lambert sur des images de nos
confrères d vu une première
moins de 24 heures après le deuxième
débat de la primaire de la gauche est
déjà le retour sur le terrain
lundi 16 janvier arnaud montebourg a
fait le déplacement aux mureaux une
ville qu'il veut prendre pour exemple il
ya ici beaucoup de créativité
d'ingéniosité pour faire vivre tout le
monde ensemble et dans l'harmonie
commune et ça c'est un effort
considérable de toutes parts il y a
beaucoup d'éléments du projet que je
porte qui finalement permettrait de
changer beaucoup de la vie des gens des
quartiers populaires aux poules molière
l'ancien ministre a échangé avec
l'association tendre la main
elle a pu lui parler d'un système de
transport permettant aux détenus de voir
leurs proches plus facilement
aujourd'hui je lui ai exposé l'idée du
taxi parloir après voilà il a été très
très réceptifs à ce que cette action là
ils pensaient pas que des actions de ce
type se faisait et voilà nous a promis
aussi de voilà deux d'être posée cette
action est de pouvoir la mener
selon un sondage réalisé après le
deuxième débat de la primaire de la
gauche 29 % des téléspectateurs ont jugé
arnaud montebourg candidat le plus
convaincant de la soirée chez les
sympathisants de gauche benoît hamon
arrive en tête
ils s'affronteront à nouveau avec
l'ensemble des candidats lors du dernier
débat ce jeudi 19 janvier
on passe désormais à une tout autre
actualité le combat d'un engin ange
prénommé n attend un petit garçon âgé de
seulement 9 ans qui est atteint d'une
maladie neurologique orpheline pour
l'aider à aller mieux ses parents lui
font que suivre des traitements mais à
l'étranger des déplacements et des
voyages et qui coûte cher à cette
famille et une soirée sera organisée ce
samedi au cabaret est débout des prêts
dans les yvelines
c'est juste à côté de cerner la ville
l'objectif est bien évidemment de
récolter des fonds pour aider cet ange
pour aider nathan le reportage d'alice
deschamps et de nicolas kirillovitch
alain ouais si vers le way se levait
tenir droit debout sur ses jambes voilà
des gestes des efforts devenu possible
pour nathan après des mois et des années
d'apprentissage
né en novembre 2007 nathan est un bébé
alors comme tous les autres il pleure
jouer passe du temps dans les bras de
ses parents
les choses se compliquent en octobre
2008 nathan devient alors sujets à des
vomissements des tremblements anormaux
il a commencé à être dans les vapes
on la change les comportements il
bougeait plus trop éveiller fixer des
choses on sait pas quoi mais fixer des
choses il a commencé à vomir
donc on avait pensé à une gastro enfin
voilà les périodes où on si c'est pas
grave quoi c'est surtout quand il a
commencé à se mettre à trembler que là
on va trouver ça bizarre
s'ensuit alors un long combat pour
nathan et sa famille combat contre des
médecins qui ne mesurent pas l'ampleur
de la maladie mais aussi pour trouver un
traitement efficace
la situation de nathan ne s'améliore
réellement qu'en 2010 avec la mise en
place d'un nouveau programme anti
épileptiques un élan de solidarité à
création une association permettent eux
de financer des thérapies à l'étranger
en espagne nathan réapprend à tenir
debout à se concentrer sa vie s'améliore
problème les stages coûte cher plusieurs
milliers d'euros pour trois semaines en
2016 on a réussi à faire de ce stage en
espagne deux semaines et trois semaines
sachant que trois semaines de stage
c'est 5000 euros donc on a fait
également un stage d'une semaine
au centre brain move à saint malo on a
testé on a financé des orthèses on a
financé une poussette
il n'y a pas que la thérapie en soit il
ya aussi tous les à côtés tout ce qui
est médicale pour l'aider au maximum la
soirée inattendue organisé le samedi 21
janvier à cerner la ville permettra de
financer une partie des stages prévus
cette année
elle permettra également de continuer le
combat de nathan chaque mardi et nous
vous proposerons dorénavant un portrait
sur les yvelinoises et les yvelinois qui
marque le département de par leurs
actions et aujourd'hui nous partons à la
rencontre du docteur christian couturier
c'est un spécialiste de la main il
dirige
il co dirige le centre sos mains de
l'hôpital de l'ouest parisien attrape un
portrait signé nicolas landry 14h
hôpital de l'ouest parisien attrape le
docteur christian couturier a revêtu sa
tenue
direction le bloc opératoire du centre
sos mains créée en 2003 cette structure
est spécialisé dans la chirurgie
orthopédique de la main au programme
huit opérations première patiente un
poignet douloureux à cause de son
cubitus
moi je suis un peu maniaque j'aime bien
que ma tablette soit bien rangé quand
c'est le bazar dessus je râle
l'intervention dure 45 minutes 6 aux
pinces si tous ces outils sont
miniaturisés pour apporter de la
précision aux praticiens avec en
complément des instruments
technologiques
voilà objectif atteint maintenant on
ferme parce que c'est toujours mieux de
refermer des patients à la fin d'une
opération sinon ça fait pas infinies
co-créateur du centre sos mains
christian couturier enchaîne les
pratiques chirurgicales
la structure est composée de huit
chirurgiens et de jeunes praticiens en
remplacement auprès du docteur couturier
ils viennent compléter leur formation
je trouve que c'est un excellent
chirurgien et puis là un avantage en
plus c'est qu'il est très pédagogue le
directeur couturier
exigeant pointilleux mais têtue de et
parfois pas toujours facile treuil avec
lui quand il n'opère pas le docteur
couturier fait des consultations à la
clinique de l'olivier de montigny le
bretonneux sa vocation chirurgicale est
né dans sa jeunesse durant ses vacances
en vendée il passait du temps avec un
vétérinaire et le cubitus
je voulais être vétérinaire
malheureusement je n'étais pas un élève
assidu et j'avais pas très très bon
dossier
ce qui fait que le bac en poche je me
suis retrouvé avec l'impossibilité de
rentrer dans les écoles vétérinaires et
en fait j'ai adoré médecine dès le
premier cours je me suis dit c'est ça
que je veux faire
l'étudiant couturier fait ses études de
médecine à nantes reçus au concours de
l'internât à paris pour devenir
spécialiste
son choix s'est porté sur la main c'est
une spécialité extrêmement variées il ya
de l'eau s'il ya du nerf il ya de
l'artère il ya des tendons il ya du mou
de la superficie de la profondeur c'est
d'une richesse incroyable
ces cinq années d'internât se déroule au
centre universitaire sos mains de
l'hôpital bichat sous les ordres du
professeur alnot un chirurgien habitué
aux internes expérimenté il avait
interdit au jeune christian couturier
d'opérer un jour des provisions masmejan
me tenait les écarteurs et je prenais le
bistouri pour la première fois et je
viens 6 le patient est alors évidemment
juste à ce moment là le professeur alnot
rentrer dans la salle il y avait un
brouhaha vent et tout d'un coup plus un
bruit et moi qui c'est tout frais moulu
je connaissais pas les règles donc je
continue d'opérer je discute avec
professeurs masmejan et là j'entends le
souffle lourds du patron dans mon cou
qui me crie couturier mais qu'est ce que
tu fais je dis monsieur jeu j'opère en
2001 il est nommé chirurgien une
opportunité se présente à lui la
possibilité de s'installer à trappes en
2003 le 24 janvier 2017 christian
couturier fêtera ses 50 ans
collaboration internationale travaux de
recherche christian couturier poursuit
plusieurs projets avec en tête ce
leitmotiv qu'il aime répéter à ses
enfants disait la lune parce que si vous
échouez vous finirez quand même parmi
les étoiles
et rendez vous mardi prochain pour un
nouveau portrait c'est la fin de ce
journal prochaine édition aux horaires
habituels ce sera mercredi très belle
soirée sur notre antenne
[Musique]